some openings need to be handled very
aggressively and the peak defense is one
of them
well guess what after watching this
video
just like me
you are going to get an aggressive and
attacking rakuta against this line which
you might want to use as a complete
surprise weapon in the tournament
practice
after E4 D6 and when white grabbed the
center with D4 black plays Knight to F6
a starting point of our opening
where the usual move here is Knight to
C3
But Here Comes the surprise guys
we are going to play Bishop to C4
looks like a blunder as we are gameting
the evil Pawn
but trust me this is exactly white ones
well black has few choices and amongst
them Knight captures E4 is the main line
however by end of this video we are also
going to look what will happen if black
declined this Gambit and continue with
his routine Beyond moves
okay first thing first
what is wrong with Knight capsules E4
looks very logical
and I'm sure if you have watched my
earlier crazy Gambit video against the
other kind you will easily able to find
the next move
yup Bishop takes F7
black responses Force he has to take it
and now the point behind the sacrifice
can be revealed
what will give this check
and after G6
he deliver another chat which not only
regain the material back
but the most important point is
yup look at where black king is situated
so we have a clear Target
and that is why our over plan is very
simple
we want to take out the queen side
pieces and Castle Quinn side where we
are going to become hair loose on the
king side with H4 H5
opening up everything
and get a tremendous attack
and practically speaking this is so
sound as black has to waste some time to
arrange the artificial castle and that
gives all Leisure to the wide to build
up This Magnificent idea
to understand this I like to show you my
personal game against the candidate
Master where my opponent continued with
Bishop to G7
I played Bishop to V3 and after Rook to
f8
Waters completing the queen side peace
development with Knight to C3
at this point black is more than happy
as he can able to do artificial castle
with King to G8
but not to worry as after we Castle
and Knight to C6
as I have described earlier this
thematic Pawn roller starting with H4
can literally create some huge problems
for the black cam
if the title players cannot handle such
lines imagine what happened to your
opponent
well in this position black has some
choices and please note that if they
continue with D5 then that make this
bishop absolutely bad and in those cases
white can continue with Queen to D3
Queen to D2 and with the H5 onslaught
black can hardly survive in these
positions
so in this game rightly so my opponent
understand the danger and he continued
with if I opening up the center
okay I continue with Knight to F3
whereupon finally my opponent complete
his peace development with Bishop to fi
attacking my queen
so wide response is false he has to give
this check
and after King to achieved
what else but this can opener H5
and I think black is already in a huge
trouble
well my opponent thought that how about
exchanging some pieces and neutralizing
the white attack
so we have the massive exchanges on the
default
e takes Knight takes Knight takes Bishop
takes
and after Bishop exchange and when he
plays Queen to F6
I thought he is more than happy as with
the last pieces white attack doesn't
have a bite
But Here Comes the movement guys where
just one move and white is winning
the question is can you spot it
you are a very good player if you see
the move G4 as this move confirmed the
white advantage
let's see how
my opponent took on D4 I simply
recapture
and now if we continue with C5 then Rook
to F4 is a very strong reply but in the
game black decided to move the bishop
which actually allow what white wants to
do namely h capital G6 Bishop to G8
Pawn captures at seven and after Bishop
two at seven and the move F4
just look at the wide
he has two connected pass Pawn running
down the board where this bishop is
completely out of the play and most
importantly if you look at the engine
Evolution it says that white is
completely rocking the show at this
Junction
so I think this model game illustrate
what is the oral plan of the white side
and how lethal this Gambit can turn out
for your opponent
okay so let's check out what to do if
black declined our wonderful Gambit and
the first move I want to consider is
Knight B to D7
kind of a black lion setter
and those of you who are following me
regularly can easily identify what what
is going to do as
we can go for the larabok attack
starting with Knight to C3 defending
over e-pawn and after E5 and Knight to
F3
I have demonstrated this attack in my
dirty chess tricks 22 episode where
White's big idea is after Bishop to E7
he wants to play Knight to G5 allowing
black to Castle
so that he can sacrifice with Bishop
takes F7
and the point is after Rook takes F7 and
the Moon Knight to E6
we get this fun position with Queen to
E8 Knight capture C7 Queen to d8 and
when why take the rook in the corner at
this point if you count the material
he has a piece plus two point advantage
and you can definitely check out this
line
where I have shown some very good
analysis
last but not least what to do if your
opponent continued with the routine Peak
defense move G6
and against this I am going to recommend
you start with Queen to E2
and White's big idea is in the main line
let's say Bishop to G7 Knight to C3 no
matter whatever black plays we are going
to deliver this thematic break E5 which
creates some great attacking and fun
position
for example if your opponent here
continue with Knight to C6
then we can play E5 and we have entered
into the mad dog attack territory which
I have covered in my DOT teacher's
tricks 57 episode where I have shown a
wonderful line that if your opponent
continue with Knight captures D4 then
you can actually take on F6
sacking your queen still get a winning
position
so please do check out guys as you are
going to get fascinated by whites
wonderful attack
well the second move I want to consider
is Top Choice from the database namely
Castle on the king side
and yup you know the answer if I Pawn
takes E5 and pawn text E5 where we are
attacking this Knight
and after Knight to G4 counter attacking
the white Pawn
white has a lethal reply here namely E6
where the idea is very simple we block
the file so we are threatening Queen
capture G4
so black response is false he has to
play F5
and after this
there is a famous trap here which goes
as follow
Bishop to G5
allowing Knight to C6 but after Knight
to F3
if you look at carefully black species
they are completely stuck
and if you check the database
in the majority of the games black has
tried the move at six which is a
complete disaster guys as just one move
and blackened back his back and go home
did you see it
congratulations if you find the move
Rook to D1
Queen has only one space to go E8 but
after this Knight to defy
and there is no stopping on C7
white is actually threatening Knight
capture C7 and trapping down the black
queen
something black has to address
immediately
well one of the high profile game from
the database continue page
Knight to E5 allowing for the queen
Escape
white continue with Knight captures E5
and after Knight captures E5 and the
move Bishop takes at six
no wonder the game finished very quickly
we have some forcing tactical moves on
the board
Knight takes C4 Bishop takes G7 King
takes G7
Queen takes E4 threatening the Knight
capture C7
so black obliged to take on E6
thinking that I'm pinning the Knight and
now I'm saving everything
but one simple check
demolish all black hole as after King to
G8
white just took on C7
and black thought that Rook to C8 hold
the ground
well guess what nope we have Knight
takes E8 Rook takes C3
Paul takes C3 and after Rook to E8 the
dust has been settled down and one can
easily say that white obtain a pawn and
an exchange which is completely winning
in this end games
last but not least what to do against
the move C6
well no price for guessing White's next
reply which is very obvious
if I Pawn takes E5 pontex E5
we already seen the consequences of
Knight to G4
so the correct response is Knight to D5
however after this white should go for
the queen side Castle
starting with Bishop to D2
well one of my recent game gives you a
clear path how you can handle this
position as black continue with some
obvious moves and still find himself at
the Troublesome
he Castle
and I immediately start attacking with
H4
seeing the H5 is looming my opponents
stop it with H5 but then white can
simply castle with a clear plan in the
mind
F3 G4 ripping apart the blacking
you might think hang on
black attack is coming faster than white
with B5 and this is exactly happened in
the game
but here is the point guys we can take
on D5 and after Pawn takes D5
what can deliver this nice attacking
punch with Bishop to G5 intending to
capture back with the Rook
okay my opponent continued with D4
I just keep attacking the center Pawn
with Knight to F3
and after Knight to C6
what else but centralizing my queen on
the E4 Square
well my opponent plays Queen to B6
but this make my task very easy as I can
now safely take on D4 and after Bishop
to D7
white has a star move in this position
namely Knight to D5 which more or less
stem the authority of the white
okay black has to move the queen and in
the game he played Queen to C5
defending on E7 but it is just an
illusion guys has after Knight takes E7
once again we get a forcing sequence
where white Gap are completely upper
hand starting with Knight takes E7
Queen takes B7 attacking the Knight
black plays Rook to E8
but then after quintix B5 it is white
who obtain
three Pawn advantage and with some
careful playing this is definitely a
winning position for the world
that's it guys I hope you really enjoy
and learn this attacking and fun Gambit
against the peer defense
remember at this point if your opponent
take on e4 then deliver this nasty punch
at the opening stage with Bishop takes
F7 where white regained the piece back
and generate attack on the king side
and instead of this if your opponent
continue with his routine
beard defense move G6
then after the following main line that
is Queen to E2 Bishop to G7 and Knight
to C3 it doesn't matter whatever black
plays White's oral idea is E5 with the
queen side Castle gives him a lot of fun
and attacking position something which
we all want against the passive peer
defense
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care